So, you're a big fan of superhero movies,
are you?
Do you regularly astound your friends with
your unrivalled superhero movie knowledge?
You might be able to recite the Christopher
Reeve Superman movies word-for-word, perhaps
you know which year every movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe franchise was released,
and you might even know why Fox thought that
awful 2009 version of Deadpool was a good
idea, but what about all that lesser known
superhero movie trivia from behind the scenes?There
are a lot of facts about movies that might
just take you by surprise - and that's what
this video is all about.
Here's a special superhero edition of twenty
rapid fire behind the scenes movie facts...
The Mask
In The Mask, when Jim Carrey is being chased
by a group of gangsters and pulls a wet condom
out of his pocket, the line "Sorry wrong pocket"
was entirely improvised by Carrey.
Watchmen
The first trailer for Watchmen premiered with
The Dark Knight in 2008, and it sparked so
much interest that it sent the graphic novel
back onto the bestseller list.
Booksellers Barnes and Noble Bookstores reported
selling out of the novel.
Howard the Duck
The role of Beverly Switzler in Howard the
Duck ultimately went to Lea Thompson, but
it was auditioned for by the likes of 80's
icon Phoebe Cates and popular vocalist Tori
Amos.
Ghost Rider
Ghost Rider star Nicolas Cage is famously
a fan of the character and actually had to
have a Ghost Rider tattoo covered up with
make-up in order to portay him on the big
screen.
The Dark Knight
The Dark Knight was the first comic book movie
to gross more than $1 billion wordwide, and
it actually made more money than its predecessor
Batman Begins' entire domestic run after only
6 days of release.
Hulk
In a scene that was deleted from the final
cut of 2003's Hulk, there was a cameo by Willie
Brown - at the time the mayor of San Francisco
- playing himself and talking to Sam Elliott's
General Ross on the phone.
Superman Returns
Amy Leland, the female actress whose voice
is used for the airplane computer in Superman
Returns, is also the same voice actress used
for Professor X's Cerebro in the X-Men films,
which are also directed by Bryan singer.
Guardians of the Galaxy
Chris Pratt improvised a lot during his performance
as Star-Lord in Guardians of the Galaxy.
Examples include the obscene gesture he gave
after being captured by the Nova Corps and
the line about his ship looking like a Jackson
Pollock painting under a blacklight.
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
Scott Adkins auditioned for the role of Batman
in Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice.
He had previously played the awful version
of Deadpool in X-Men Origins: Wolverine in
stunt scenes that Ryan Reynolds wasn't needed
for.
Deadpool
In Deadpool, the titular character says that
he looks like he was "bitten by a radioactive
shar-pei" - a wrinkly breed of dog.
This is a reference to a Deadpool comic in
which the character said that he looks like
a cross between Ryan Reynolds and a shar-pei.
X-Men: Apocalypse
Tómas Lemarquis plays Caliban - an albino
mutant - in X-Men: Apocalypse.
It is the third movie in which Lemarquis has
played an albino - the others being Noi the
Albino and Snowpiercer - in spite of the fact
that he is not albino himself.
Green Lantern
In Green Lantern, San Diego doubled-up as
the fictional Coast City, and one of the shots
from the movie shows Parallax over the San
Diego Convention Center, which is famously
the home of Comic-Con.
Spawn
John Leguizamo - who played the villainous
and clown-like Violator in the Spawn movie
- described wearing the required fatsuit as
"Like a penis wearing a condom".
Batman Returns
The late Burgess Meredith, who played the
Penguin in the Adam West Batman television
series of the 1960s, was asked to play the
Penguin's father in the opening of Batman
Returns, but illness sadly prevented him from
doing so.
Hellboy
Ron Perlman legitimately broke a rib while
filming the subway scenes in Hellboy.
He crazily jumped onto a train that was coming
towards him at about 45 miles per hour.
Tank Girl
Rapper Ice-T was paid an astonishing $800,000
to appear as the kangaroo-like T-Saint in
the awful 1995 comic book movie Tank Girl.
Blade
Marvel legend Stan Lee famously cameos in
most Marvel movies, but he didn't appear in
Blade.
He did film a scene, but it was cut from the
final movie.
He played one of the cops that entered the
blood club and discovered Quinn's body on
fire after Blade had been there.
Suicide Squad
It has been said that, in order for her to
get in the mood to play the Enchantress in
Suicide Squad, Cara Delevingne listened to
rock music ranging from Nick Cave to Megadeth.
Spider-Man 3
For the filming of the crane accident scene
in Spider-Man 3, Bryce Dallas Howard performed
her own stunts, unaware that she was actually
pregnant at the time of filming.
Steel
In the utterly garbage Steel movie, Shaquille
O'Neal had no choice but to do all of his
own stunts, as the movie's producers were
unable to find a 7' 1" stunt double for him.
Thanks for watching this special superhero
edition of twenty rapid fire behind the scenes
movie facts.
Did you know about any of these?
Which other great superhero movie facts do
you know of?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.